congratulations you made it you're about
to start the seventh class of seven in
concise clear and confident
communication if for some reason you
found this last video first then you can
go back and do the whole course
otherwise if you've been going all the
way through I'm really happy for you I
encourage you to watch these videos as
many times as you need to to really make
these tips and strategies habit because
that's where it's going to start to make
a difference in your life so let's wrap
things
[Music]
up
in our previous lesson we looked at how
to get rid of fillers in lesson seven
we're going to hit on confident
nonverbals so tip seven is confident
nonverbals enhance your message all the
previous six lessons are mostly to do
with words and how you sound verbally
but these non-verbal messages can
enhance or detract from what you're
saying so people form Impressions about
how you come across through nonverbal
communication distracting nonverbals
will diminish or take away from your
communication your message and confident
nonverbals will add to it to say
something with confidence means that you
sound and look confident not just that
you're saying confident words strategy
number one use direct eye contact most
people drastically underestimate the
power of direct eye
contact make direct eye contact when
speaking and listening both both are
very important strive for 80% of the
time in your conversations and 99% of
the time during presentations most of us
underestimate the need that others have
for us to be looking directly at them
when we speak and so those numbers will
give you a good
gauge Adrien feram a PhD researcher
that's spent a lot of time working on
eye contact said The Confident the
bright and the socially dominant look
more with direct eye contact while it is
the opposite for the socially
anxious in this Society we generally
interpret direct eye contact as
confident and the lack of direct eye
contact as signaling some kind of issue
oftentimes social anxiety or even just a
lack of confidence in general direct
means right into their eyes not like
these two people who are looking
elsewhere sometimes above people's head
sometimes over their shoulders you do
not want to be in this kind of situation
when you're looking directly at somebody
it says hey I see you and they look back
and it's hey I see you too there's a
connection there so what is that look
like in practice like you're looking
directly into the lens of a camera
someone says hey look right here we're
going to take a picture you want to look
right into their eyes and again in a
conversation it's 80% of the time you
want you don't want to stare but you
want to look at them the vast majority
of the time to show them that you're
communicating you're locked into what
you're saying and you're locked into
listening to what they say strategy two
is to avoid upt talk this is a nonverbal
tendency upt talk describes the upward
inflection used to make a statement
sound like a question sometimes called
upspeak and it sounds like this I wanted
to meet to discuss the plans I was
hoping to have that nailed down today
many of the new hirers need this
training
badly now clearly these are not
questions but you've probably heard
upspeak or upt talk from people maybe
you do it it's becoming much more common
among the younger generation and it's
become a real issue in professional
settings but instead of this you want
your sentences to go down at the end so
if there's a period you want them to go
down like the period signals I wanted to
meet to discuss the plants I was hoping
to have that nailed down today many of
the new hires need this training badly
that's a statement and that's what it
should sound like you may not realize
however that you're up talking a lot of
people don't even know they're doing it
I recommend asking a trusted friend to
listen to your talk to see if you do it
and then commit if you are doing up talk
I want you to commit to landing at the
end of sentences and boy is this a hard
habit to break but it's well worth it
because you don't want to sound like the
person who's never sure of what they're
saying strategy three is to smile who
doesn't like a smile people often even
don't realize that they're scowling or
have that stone-faced expression when
they're walking around talking to people
but many people just don't smile and as
a result they don't sound confident they
don't look confident to other people
even if their words are confident
they're not going to come across as
feeling very comfortable with what they
say because confident people smile so
you want to practice smiling a little as
you talk I don't think you should
plaster on a phony smile that's just not
me but you want to practice smiling a
little so in other words instead of a
stone face or that scow be aware of your
facial expression and if you're happy
then show it with your face Sarah
Silverman a comedian was talking to a
young friend of hers who had that scowl
on her face even though she claimed she
wasn't upset and Sarah Silverman said
I'm going to change your life right now
if that's your default face put a smile
on there so a lot of us need to warm up
our facial expression so we come across
more confident in what we're saying
so use confident nonverbals our takeaway
strategies from this lesson are to use
direct eye contact that is number one
avoid up talk and if you do this you
want to ask a friend to listen and give
you that give you that advice and then
come down at the end of your sentences
and then practice smiling a little warm
that face up and communicate that
confidence so practice these tips and
strategies as Jim Ron said motivation is
what gets you started habit is what
keeps you going speaking of nice concise
statements that's an amazing one and it
couldn't be more true so you were
learning some things by watching these
lessons once I recommend you watch them
as many times as you need to to put
these tips into practice and make them a
habit it's been a pleasure learning with
you through this mini course a concise
clear and confident communication I
encourage you to put them into practice
and I look forward to learning with you
in the future sure